These are the top 5 most overpowered devil
fruits in One Piece.
Starting with the Brush fruit.
Yes, that’s right.
We are already starting with a shocker.
And while this fruit may surprise many of
you, let’s take a look at just how incredible
these powers are.
In chapter 754, the samurai Kanjuro first
demonstrates the fruit’s powers . To put
it simply, the fruit allows its user to produce
ink and then anything that is painted with
this ink can come alive.
And this ability makes it probably THE.
MOST.
ADAPTABLE fruit ever.
Need some food?
Just paint it.
Need a way to fly?
Easy.
Need an overpowered destructive force of nature?
A robot that can scale the Grand Line?
Want five dragon Kaidos raining down destruction
on the battlefield?
Literally anything is possible!
Now of course, the strength of the creations
depends on the skill of the artist, but in
the hands of someone who is really good at
art, this fruit is truly incredible.
Although, we initially though the creations
were weak to water, we later learned that
they are not which makes them even more powerful.
We’ve even seen Kanjuro create walking,
talking clones of other people.
And while these clones seem like they can’t
take much damage, if the user is creative,
they can still be devastating in battle.
The power even allowed Kanjuro to create this
creepy giant bl which set the entirety of
Kaido’s castle on fire and threatened to
take out every single person fighting on the
island.
And we don’t even know
if Kanjuro actually awakened his fruit or
not.
Since awakened fruits usually affect their
environment and this one did not, there is
a decent chance that this fruit has an even
more overpowered level that we never got to
see.
One possibility for awakening could allow
the user to turn the environment into ink
which can then be used to create anything.
Or maybe the user can awaken different brushes
so that anyone can bring paintings to life.
Either way, the Brush fruit feels like one
of the most criminally underrated and insanely
adaptable devil fruits in the story.
And if you were surprised by the Brush fruit
making it into the Top 5, then you won’t
believe what fruits are at number one and
two on this list.
And STILL, it might be NOTING compared to
the terrifying, god-like, life-warping powers
of the Soul Fruit.
In chapter 835, we get an explanation for
the abilities of the fruit’s current user,
Big Mom.
Basically, the fruit allows the user to manipulate
the soul, also known as life-span, of other
people.
She can take the life-span under certain conditions
and then turn other objects into living, conscious
beings using this stolen life span.
Like I said, she is literally creating life.
And like the other fruits on this list, it
isn’t simply overwhelmingly powerful in
battle.
It also has so many other mind-bending uses
that make the fruit so special.
As I already mentioned, Big Mom uses the Soul
fruit to bring objects to life.
These are called homies which can move around
and act independently, but they are mostly
forced to obey her commands.
These homies also retain some personality
and memories from the person whose soul they
were created with.
Let’s look at some examples of just how
broken this ability truly is.
Big Mom basically brought the entire forest
on her island to protect her home from intruders.
She made an army out of chess pieces.
She can animate food and water.
She also used her own soul to create special
homies, as we see with Zeus, Prometheus, Napoleon,
and Hera, which she uses to fly and use elemental
powers such as fire and lightning.
So basically the user can create life as long
as they have soul available to use.
There are some limitations to these powers.
Big Mom is only able to steal life-span from
people who freely offer it or people who are
afraid of her.
Naturally most people are scared of Big Mom,
but we don’t know if this is a rule for
the devil fruit or only for Big Mom.
For example, could someone else with the fruit
steal life-span from someone they love or
someone who is weak?
In addition, souls can’t be infused into
corpses or other living people.
The homies are also somewhat independent,
and can even betray their creator if they
have enough motivation or, like we see with
Nami, if someone has a vivre card of the Soul
fruit user.
Soul can also be stolen once it is extracted
from someone else.
We have seen another person use this devil
fruit, Mother Carmel.
Before Big Mom, uhh, ate her, she created
a homie from fire named Pandora.
And while Big Mom was never confirmed to be
awakened, it is possible that the awakening
of this devil fruit is actually these dark
blobs that we see on whole cake island.
These blobs were created by Big Mom and are
able to gather life-span from people who offer
it.
So without a doubt, the Soul Fruit is super
powerful and adaptive, able to create devastating
weapons, bring objects to life, and even transform
entire islands to match the desires of the
user.
Which is absolutely insanely overpowered,
but it doesn’t even come close to this literal
god fruit that broke the entire one piece
fandom when it was revealed in chapter 1044.
The Mythical Zoan Human Fruit: Model Sun God
Nika.
Of course it had to be on this list.
How could it not?
Many previous top devil fruit videos have
never included Luffy’s rubber fruit because,
honestly, it isn’t that great.
But since chapter 1044 when we first see Luffy’s
awakening and are told that his fruit is actually
a mythical Zoan, this fruit has become one
of the most overpowered in the entire story.
Not only does this fruit turn the user’s
body into rubber, and all the crazy things
we’ve seen Luffy do with that, but upon
awakening they are able to freely manifest
their imagination in the world.
Remember all those crazy things you imagined
doing as a kid.
Well, Luffy can do them.
In just the short time since this reveal,
we have seen Luffy turn people and objects
into rubber.
He can catch lightning.
Punch with fire.
Create actual googles out of his hair.
Who knows, maybe he’ll even be able to imitate
other devil fruits in the future.
And all of this on top of having incredible
strength and endurance.
One downside of the fruit is that using the
powers is probably costing Luffy his life-span.
We are told this by many of his opponents
and can even see him grow incredibly weak
whenever he is using a new power.
Besides this weakness, we don’t know the
true limits or even the ultimate powers of
this devil fruit, so make sure to subscribe
to the channel as we will talk all about it
in future videos.
And this devil fruit is another one where
the powers are good on their own, but they
are significantly enhanced by the person using
the fruit.
In this case, Luffy is a perfect match for
the fruit because he can fully utilize his
joyful spirit and his limitless imagination,
which is probably the reason he was the first
person to awaken it in over 800 years.
But as ridiculously overpowered as the Nika
fruit is, you’ll probably be surprised to
hear that it still falls short of the reality-bending
powers of the number two fruit on this list.
A fruit that you probably didn’t have on
your radar for this list, but it is easily
second the most insane fruit on this list,
and not for the reasons you might think.
And that is Bartholomew kuma’s Paw Fruit.
And I can almost guarantee that in chapter
484 when this fruit was introduced that no
one could imagine the absurd capabilities
of this power.
When this fruit is eaten, the user’s hands
grow these paw pads which can repel anything.
And I mean anything.
Swords, ranged attacks, bullets.
And that is hardly the limit of its powers.
We saw in Thriller Bark and Sabaody that the
user can launch people across the world.
They can compress air to make a bomb.
And even more mind-blowing is that it can
repel intangible concepts such as pain, and,
as we learned recently, memories and imagination.
And this is where the true power of this fruit
lies.
If it can truly repel these intangible aspects
of a person then could it also be the way
that some devil fruits are created.
I mean the genius scientist Dr. Vegapunk tells
us that devil fruits were born of people’s
desires.
So could it be possible that Kuma or a person
from the past used this devil fruit to repel
a person’s desire in order to create a new
devil fruit?
How insane would that be?
If you desire to be a soft, bouncy pillow?
Perhaps Kuma can push out your desire and
put it into a devil fruit.
You want to be a mythical unicorn?
Well, here you go.
There may be some limits that we do not know
of yet, but there are some crazy possibilities.
For example, could the user even repel their
own pain?
This could basically let them heal themselves
whenever they want.
Could they repel a person's age to make them
younger?
Their personality to change who they are?
Truly, this fruit is incredibly overpowered
and I personally can’t wait to learn more
about it along with the number one fruit coming
up next.
But before we get there, here are some honorable
mentions that just barely missed out on my
top five.
Now if I had made this list before 2022, I
certainly would have had Law’s Ope-Ope no
mi on my list.
I mean the user basically becomes a god within
their “room”.
And this little girl’s Hobby fruit is another
insane power, as she can literally turn anyone
she touches into a little toy slave.
Also missing out are some of the most destructive
fruits in One Piece like the Magma fruit,
the Tremor fruit, the Light and Darkness fruits,
and even Kaido’s mythical fish fruit which
allows him to unleash the elemental powers
of a dragon.
But we’re ranking the top 5 devil fruits
that are way too overpowered for what they
originally were supposed to be.
And all of these fruits I just listed do pretty
much exactly what you’d think they do.
Make stuff go boom.
But even still, you might be surprised to
learn that despite how incredibly powerful
all of those fruits are, none of them even
comes close to the insanely overpowered abilities
of number one.
It’s time to discuss the Brain Fruit.
In chapter 1066, we see the famous Dr. Vegapunk
for the first time in a flashback on the ruins
of the scholar island, Ohara.
Now, we always knew that Vegapunk was a genius,
but it completely shocked everyone that he
was the user of the newly introduced Brain
fruit.
Just one chapter later, we learn that the
main power this fruit grants is the ability
to instantly memorize information and limitlessly
store all that knowledge in the user’s head.
And while this fruit may not directly be the
best fighting devil fruit, it is incredibly
overpowered based on the effects it has on
the one piece world.
And I will argue that there is literally no
one in the story who has changed the current
one piece world as much as Vegapunk.
And while we know he was born a genius, the
Brain fruit is what truly allowed him to change
the world.
And let’s talk about the crazy influence
these powers have in the story.
First, Vegapunk designed these Sea Prism lined,
self-propelled ships, which allows the marines
to cross the calm belt safely.
And while this may not seem like a big deal,
remember that the world is separated by these
stretches of calm seas and the Red Line.
Basically, if someone wants to go to one of
the other blues or the Grand Line, they have
to go through Reverse Mountain, climb the
Red Line, or risk sailing through the calm
belt.
So allowing the World Government easy access
to each part of the world is a massive advantage
over normal people and pirates which allows
them to control the world.
And this was all thanks to Vegapunk’s scientific
genius and the Brain Fruit.
Besides the ships, let’s take a look at
the insane fighting forces that Vegapunk has
created with the help of the Brain fruit.
He has made giant robots, armies of super
powered cyborgs, and the Seraphim, which are
nearly invincible genetically enhanced clones.
Seriously, who in the entire world could stand
up to all of these ridiculous battle weapons
that Vegapunk has created.
And even more impressive is Vegapunk’s research
into devil fruits.
He has successfully cloned other Zoan and
paramecia devil fruits like the Swim fruit,
the Love fruit, and Kaido’s Mythical Fish
Fruit.
So if he has a whole stockpile of other fruits,
just imagine the army that he could create.
And with his brain and enough time, I’m
sure he could even come up with more weapons
to counter devil fruit abilities.
And while many of these advancements were
possible because of the unique combination
of the Brain fruit and Vegapunk genius, I
think it is fair to say that even a normal
person who ate this fruit would have the potential
to become a super genius if they decided to
study enough.
And the final part of this fruit to discuss
is what a possible awakening could look like.
Other reality-warping paramecia awakenings
that we have seen like Law’s Kroom or Kid’s
Magnetism have allowed the user to grant powers
of their devil fruit to a part of the environment.
For Vegapunk this could mean that he is able
to gain the memories and knowledge by touching
other people or objects in the world, thereby
increasing the knowledge that he could gather.
In my opinion there is not a single devil
fruit out there that even comes close to reaching
this level of overpowered, but if you want
to prove me wrong and find an ever more op
fruit that no one thought about, check out
this video right here, where I explain ever
single devil fruit in one piece.
Shanks for watching.